update in the trial of former
minneapolis police officer derrick
chauvin
closing arguments started today was the
prosecution and defense's
last chances to make their case in
regarding the death of george floyd
eric runge reporting it's been one of
the most
watched trials in recent memory a former
cop accused of killing george floyd
during an arrest in minneapolis last may
this case is exactly what you thought
when you saw it
first when you saw that video it is
exactly that
you can believe your eyes as it did in
opening statements prosecutors again
played the now infamous video and
repeated for the jury over and over
again
nine minutes and 29 seconds the amount
of time
former officer derrick chauvin pinned
floyd to the ground with his knee
what the defendant did
to george floyd killed him
it was ruled a homicide the defendant is
charged
with murder the state has really focused
on
the 9 minutes and 29 seconds it's not
the proper analysis
because the 9 minutes and 29 seconds
ignores
the previous 16 minutes and 59 seconds
defense attorney eric nelson says a
reasonable police officer would have
walked up to the scene saw a large man
suspected of using counterfeit money
fighting with officers while an
angry crowd gathered and would have used
a non-deadly force to control him
human behavior is unpredictable and
nobody knows it better
than a police officer over three weeks
more than 40 witnesses testified
including medical and use of force
experts and there was also emotional
testimony from witnesses who were there
that night in may
the cause of death has become a critical
aspect of the trial
the defense says it wasn't chauvin's
knee that killed floyd
but drugs and an enlarged heart as well
as other medical issues
the prosecution pointed to the fact
chauvin's knee stayed on floyd's neck
even after he was unconscious the
defendant caused
george floyd's death he did
the state proved that beyond a
reasonable doubt the defendant is guilty
and that was eric runge reporting the
jury will be sequestered during
deliberations now as a reminder
if convicted of the most serious charge
shoving could be looking at 40 years